With movie studios spending millions to bring
comic book superheroes to life, and outshine
the competition, you would think that almost
all of their efforts and energy winds up on
the screen.
But you'd be surprised to learn that some
of the best superhero stories come from behind
the camera, before they ever start rolling.
Here is another dose of insider trivia in
our latest edition of Know Your Movies: 20
Mind-Blowing Facts About Superhero Movies.
Man of Steel
The latest Superman origin story skips over
most of Clark discovering his abilities as
a kid, but we do get a look at his horrifying
X-Ray vision.
If the shots seem familiar, they should: the
special effects team turned to John Carpenter's
"They Live" for the overall look.
The movie gives only a short look at the planet
Krypton before it's destroyed, but to make
it seem real, Snyder hired a linguist to create
an entire language, alphabet, and sentence
structure for the ancient society.
The art team made sure to create, then carve
Kryptonian proverbs all over the props and
sets - ready to be translated for any fan
with some free time.
Batman V Superman
It's every kid's dream to be the Batman, so
it's no surprise that during production of
Batman V Superman, Ben Affleck asked the studio
if he could have the Dark Knight costume when
filming wrapped.
They told him he could - but would have to
cover the $100,000 cost.
He decided some photos were a nice compromise.
Dawn of Justice might mark the first time
that Batman and Superman share the screen,
but that's not the entire story for the stars
who made the heroes movie icons.
To get a glimpse of the World's Finest an
entire generation dreamed of, just pick up
Speechless, starring Michael Keaton and Christopher
Reeve.
Fans don't know how DC's movie universe will
play out, but history has already been made,
thanks to Ben Affleck, after playing former
Superman actor George Reeves in Hollywoodland,
Ben Affleck is now the first and only man
to play both of DC's biggest heroes on film
- and that's one record that he'll probably
hold for good.
Guardians of the Galaxy Star-Lord's ship might
seem cutting-edge, but he reveals that his
romantic exploits would make it into a Jackson
Pollock painting under a black light.
The black light was scripted, but Chris Pratt's
censor-tempting punchline wasn't.
Director James Gunn only left it in when the
line got the biggest laugh from early test
audiences.
The creepy Sakaraan soldiers working for Ronan
don't get much time in the spotlight, but
when they do, it's James Gunn provided their
voices, along with his assistant, Simon Hatt.
Gunn even makes a cameo of sorts, as the unmasked
soldier killed by Yondu.
Ant-Man
The Marvel comedy has plenty of pop culture
references, but one of its best never made
it to screen.
Paul Rudd had the idea of Michael Pena's character
greeting him outside the prison blasting Peter
Gabriel's "In Your Eyes" as a nod to the teen
classic Say Anything.
They even filmed the scene... then found out
how much the song would cost to license, and
cut it.
Iron Man 3
The Miss Chatanooga pageant is played for
a single laugh in the movie, but the contestant
is anything but random.
When casting the part, director Shane Black
turned to Yvonne Zima, the seven-year-old
star of The Long Kiss Goodnight, one of his
earlier screenplays.
Iron Man 2
When Tony starts investigating his new nemesis,
Whiplash, an old photo shows that villain
was once arrested for selling plutonium.
It's not a case of photoshop, but a real photo
of actor Mickey Rourke from a drug arrest
in his younger days.
X-Men
Fans were probably too distracted by the introduction
of Rogue in the first X-Men movie to notice
the major cameo.
The truck driver who drops her off in a northern
Canada town is actor George Buza, the unforgettable
voice of Beast from the classic X-Men cartoon
series.
CG effects have come a long way since the
year 2000, but even back then, the crew found
a clever way to create the teleporting mutant
boy playing basketball all by himself.
Just hire triplets, and paint them out one
by one, and you'll have fans wondering just
how much special effects makes possible.
Batman Begins
It may have all been one big fake-out, but
the first version of the immortal Ra's al
Ghul is hard to forget, played by Ken Watanabe
But don't bother trying to decipher the language
he's speaking, being translated by Liam Neeson's
secret villain - it's gibberish, made up by
the actor with some Japanese words scattered
for flavor.
The first scene that Christian Bale actually
filmed with co-stars Michael Caine and Morgan
Freeman features him waking from a drug-induced
sleep.
As incredible as his performance turned out,
his co-stars weren't quite as impressed when
Bale actually fell asleep in the Wayne bed,
starting the shoot being poked awake by his
butler, Alfred.
Somehow, it seems like a perfect start.
Deadpool
Some of the best laughs of the movie come
from the scenes shared by Deadpool and his
favorite cab driver, Dopinder.
But fans might not realize that the driver
is actually a tribute to a childhood friend
of star Ryan Reynolds who passed away when
he was, fitting with the movie's tone, struck
by lightning.
For real.
Instead of artwork, Wade Wilson decorates
his house with paper targets from a gun range
he apparently frequents.
The paper targets aren't randomly chosen,
but authentic Firearms Qualification Targets
used by the Royal Canadian Mounted Police.
They wouldn't be hard to find, since Ryan
Reynolds' father and brother are both Mounties.
The movie confirms that Deadpool lives in
the same universe as the X-Men, but the shared
universe is just as active behind the scenes.
Actress Olivia Munn first tried her hand at
a mutant auditioning for the role of Deadpool's
girlfriend.
She didn't land the part, but producer Simon
Kinberg decided she was too good to pass up,
casting her as Psylocke in X-Men: Apocalypse
instead.
The Wolverine
With his second solo movie, actor Hugh Jackman
finally got into the physical shape he had
always envisioned for Wolverine.
The results were staggering, but in the actual
movie, only a handful of scenes actually showed
them.
To make the most of Jackman's work - and the
attention it would grab - most of the marketing
was tweaked to feature the actor in all his
topless glory.
Suicide Squad
It's hard to think of another actress who
could capture the no-nonsense authority of
Amanda Waller like Oscar-nominated Viola Davis.
But the studio was apparently eager to land
another world-famous actress for the part:
Oprah Winfrey.
We still can't decide if that was a terrible
idea, or an incredible one.
Captain America: The Winter Soldier
It might seem like fantasy, but the shi-based
satellite launch platform infiltrated by Cap
in the movie;s opening scenes is an actual
ship.
Apparently, after landing the practical set,
the directors decided to find a way to work
the satellite technology into the plot of
the script - a bit backwards, but it paid
off.
Those are the bits of trivia, easter eggs
and behind-the-scenes secrets we found for
some of our favorite superhero movies, but
which ones did we miss?
Let us know in the comments, and remember
to subscribe to ur channel for more videos
like this one.